[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a esta escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español
américa latina es una región rica por lo
que su música goza vive cotidianamente a
partir de ella sones danzones y otro
tipo de música llena constantemente es
la vida de los latinoamericanos y
recibimos en este escala en parís a
simón bolsing el pianista nacido en
estrasburgo quien presenta su nuevo
álbum ritmos queridos bienvenido sea'
muchas gracias gracias por acompañarnos
en esta escala en parís durante su vida
de artista usted ha recorrido diversos
países notablemente de américa del sur y
es de ahí precisamente que se ha
inspirado para la elaboración de este
álbum de jazz ritmos queridos
d
[Música]
no
no no
[Música]
simón como les nace la idea de este
álbum de jazz yo viaje tuve la suerte de
viajar y de vivir en venezuela cuando
tenía 20 años y me apasioné de por esa
música una pasión que surgió en ese
momento cuando descubrí esa cultura esa
riqueza y esa gente esa música
no me ha quitado nunca sea pasión la si
sigue ahí en fuerte vigente y sigo
inspirándome de la música tradicional y
componiendo arreglando escribiendo
tocando música mía pero inspirada
directamente de los ritmos que me gustan
esos ritmos que yo llamo los ritmos
queridos los queridos precisamente es
una excelente mezcla un mestizaje entre
el jazz una música por excelencia
universal pero también músicas que
vienen de argentina de mexico de
colombia de perú de brasil y en este
sentido como hecho usted para integrar
como imagina un músico la integración
precisamente de ritmos que aparecen a
veces tan diferentes aunque claro en el
origen de la mayoría de los ritmos
llamados latinoamericanos pues provienen
de áfrica pues ellos tienen no menos lo
mismo ingrediente pero diferentes
recetas y solo apasionante de ese
continente que tú consigue en cada país
el aporte indígena el aporte europeo y
el aporte africano pero con diferentes
proporciones como si hubiera hecho
10 receta diferente ex pero con los tres
mismos ingredientes
y como respeto a la manera de utilizarla
musicalmente pues yo soy pianista y muy
poco existe el piano en la música
tradicional que si no está y por eso
mismo en me interesa porque está sobre
todo siempre el canto y el tambor y el
canto definía la melodía el tambor de
fin y el ritmo y con el piano yo me
puedo ubicar justo entre los dos y hago
lo que quiero
excelente hablemos de lo que son las
músicas las piezas que componen este
álbum de ritmos queridos 9 concretamente
que llevan casi una hora de placer
absoluto estamos escuchando
hay que decirlo empieza usted con
quitapesares es una pieza un joropo de
venezuela pero que también se juega
bastante en seda se toca bastante en
colombia muy famoso claro quitapesares
un estándar total de todavenezuela de
toda colombia de todo está de susana en
esa zona que donde se toque al grupo que
se llaman logia no sé
no era exactamente el joropo tiene 34
género creo dentro del cual el kit a
pesar de un género quizás no es una
canción así que un género y este álbum
de tenemos queridos también nos lleva se
pasea se llevase transcurre hacia otros
países como por ejemplo brasil
[Música]
vos edin de una música de claude debussy
y antonio carlos jobim es maravillosa
esta interpretación háblenos de esta
música precisamente si esto fue una idea
del contrabajista del grupo de el señor
wiley y kiko que me dijo oye esta
melodía que es la introducción de
djindjic él escribió antonio carlos
jobim se parece
un aero día de debussy claudio de
debussy que la escribió para el canto
pero que la tocan muchos los
contrabajistas del día y la conocía y
entonces estuvimos reflexionando y
decidimos engancharlo y ponerlo de
introducción de ahí surge el puente de
debussy hacia antonio carlos que es una
especie de ida y vuelta no porque
empezar o vice carlos yo viene alguien
vuelve a hacer le hice un arreglo a ying
de ahí estábamos trabajando ese tema
porque le des y ponerle en el ritmo de y
que es un reboot y me encanta que
proviene más bien de bahía
y la canción en sí tiene que ver más
bien con un río de janeiro y
directamente la zona un poquito del sur
sería eso una mezcla en sí y como se
mezcló con un con claudio del bus y al
final cuando terminamos volvemos con la
conclusión de bus guau debo decir le
decimos que a mí particularmente la que
más me gustó de todas es razón para
opción que no me lleva de cuba a brasil
los le llevan nos trae
y me llamó mucho la atención porque
claro el danzón es una música de origen
africano que se instala en cuba que
viaja méxico pero hoy um es ni más ni
menos que uno de los grandes personajes
de los orillas en estos siete personajes
de la naturaleza y curiosamente o si no
que es la reina la diosa de los ríos de
las aguas y es la diosa del amor
danson para opciones nos dice
simplemente con el título nos está
diciendo todo si le pusieron súbitamente
para no ponerle 8 un como dicen lo
cubano que la misma llosa pero bueno en
el panteón afro cubano tiene los nombres
en español y en un afro brasilero tienen
el número de portugués
y por eso le puse el número en portugués
para mostrar esa esa el hecho que este
para los dos las dos culturas que
asignar a la misma son este álbum de
jazz lo compone usted lo forma con un
trío precisamente hemos hablado ya de
will y kiko pero también está el
baterista lukas scalabrini que juega con
las críticas cometidas de una manera
extraordinaria y también está álvaro
pérez que le dijeron ellos cuando usted
les propuso hacer este árbol es muy
interesante porque una cosa es la idea
de que está imaginando pero con un trío
así cuál es la opinión que le recibieron
recibieron al decir te baja para mezclar
música latinoamericana y el jazz le
interesa muchísimo es muy interesante
pienso la propuesta y ellos me dieron
hoy es sí pero tiene que mostrarnos que
decir no tirano indicación de referencia
para escuchar para aprender el músico
tiene la suerte de hacer ese trabajo de
no solamente tocar pero a veces tenían
la oportunidad de buscar de informarse
ahora con un internet youtube y spotify
y cosas así de manera de tener miles
miles de referencias para escuchar y
entender los códigos de la música
tradicional
y entonces por eso le gustó mucho la
propuesta pero yo ya tenían alguna
experiencia de contacto con la música
latinoamericana cualquiera de sus
vertientes de américa del sur el caribe
estuve de ir a venezuela con lucas
calandrino en el 2010 baterista el
baterista y entonces tuve a él tuvo el
contacto ahí está esta vez
y le encantó totalmente desde sicilia y
por eso me interesa también a mí su
manera de tocar porque el cis ella no
tiene mucho que ver con su tradición
ésta está menos separado de la tradición
que el europeo en general
y sobre todo con la música ternaria que
la música siciliana externar jazz y la
música venezuela también por eso hay una
cercanía finalmente y la cierta cercanía
pero una manera de tocar diferente
totalmente bien personal de luca bueno
estos tres músicos junto con usted claro
se llevan el palmarés del disco pero no
sólo son ellos los que justo caron en el
disco hay alguien que llama mucho la
atención cuando usted está tocando la
samba la pomeña el bombo y esa nariz
pilar que lo toca el bombo con una
sensualidad extraordinaria no es
exactamente el nice fue la que prestó el
instrumento abuelo
claro por eso le puse el crédito pero él
le toca el mismo look a el boom por la
acción de manera muy sensual verdadero
me declaro y dije y es una parte que
parece bien sencilla pero que no es
fácil captarlo la sensualidad de la
samba argentina es una cosa increíble
y ojalá pude pueda llevar a luca y a
willy el trío para allá para la entidad
del noroeste argentino para que vean
como enlazan vaya claro que además la
samba argentina nada que ver con la
samba brasileña no muy segura de las
piezas que se tocan guardan la distancia
en el valle del pañuelo la estabilidad
no no no es una belleza total
y dígame simón antes de haber hecho
ritmos queridos usted hizo otro álbum
que se llama cantos queridos que también
está referido a américa latina
es una suerte de homenaje a la tradición
al mestizaje como se puede interpretar
este contacto entre usted y américa
latinoamérica de sus acta mente una
imagina para mí la tradición es súper
importante y cuando lo ubique que estaba
todavía mucha muy viviente en
latinoamérica me fascine con eso porque
no es el caso en francia lamentablemente
menos mal está volviendo a salir aquí en
francia allá es vivo está en el
cotidiano los niños aprenden la
tradición de la escuela en venezuela a
los niveles dan un 4 para que toquen el
4 es yo pienso que esa música en la
tradición está todo está lo cotidiano
está una historia del pueblo está lo
social está la geografía está la
historia está la religión está el amor
y tiene todo así que cuando tuve la
riqueza de esa música dice y para qué
para qué vamos a componer vamos a tocar
eso vamos a
y mantenerlo vivo a agravarlo para que
siga para que nos des aprendes aparezca
pésimo y una próxima aventura después de
este disco de este álbum de jazz
maravilloso con su trío ya está
imaginando otro tipo de música otro tipo
de aporte de mezcla de mestizaje europeo
y latinoamericano claro el yo pienso que
la aventura nunca se parará tengo la
suerte programar los encuentros tambor y
canto en la cité de la musique de
marseille y todos los años hacemos un
nuevo encuentro
y vamos a hacer una nueva
en producción este año en 2020 con
mezcla de cuatro países cuba brasil
argentina el perú y también tengo un
proyecto muy interesante con álvaro
pérez que grabó un un tema en el disco
de ritmos queridos de él está el tema
uruguayo pues muy bien estamos llegando
ya a extra y de final de escala en parís
no me queda sino agradecerle a simón
bolsing er su presencia en esta escala
mil gracias y volver hacia acompañado a
ustedes les damos una nueva cita aquí la
próxima semana en otra escala en parís
[Música]
pero